this is the post-production technique
which many in hollywood believe makes
real guns redundant it's a debate fired
by the shooting death of cinematographer
helena hutchins
what you get with a toy gun worth no
danger at all
is that
eric is a visual effects artist using a
toy gun to replicate a real pistol the
dirty secret is
it costs a lot less money to do it this
way
and
90 of the time real gunfire doesn't show
up on camera anyway and i have to fix it
later anyway
police in new mexico are investigating
how live ammunition came to being a gun
fired by alec baldwin
we need some help as
director and our camera manager my woman
has been shot script assistant mamie
mitchell made the
now being 911 by leading lawyer gloria
allred she feels that she deserves the
truth
that others on the set
need to know
why there was a breakdown
leading to a tragedy
i do believe it's gross negligence in
many ways at the absolute minimum
i asked the producers of rust including
alec baldwin about those claims of gross
negligence they say they weren't aware
of any official complaint made about the
safety of props or weapons on set but
helena hutchins contemporaries say
there's bigger questions for the film
industry
cinematographer autumn eakin is leading
the call for helena's law which would
ban real guns on film sets
the stakes are just too high to
to qualify having
um weapons like that on set um in in a
in a
a magical movie making place it's not
we're not you know we're not soldiers
we're not
at war we're not there's just no there's
no
justification anymore for me
the rock actor dwayne johnson has
pledged that his production company will
only use rubber guns from now on it's a
commitment spurred by a tragedy which
could change filmmaking forever martha
kellner sky news hollywood